- All right y'all she's a TV legend.
After 11 years hosting The Today Show,
she's embracing her next chapter in life.
You can read all about
it in her new book called
'It's Never Too Late'.
Make the next act of your life,
the best act of your life.
It comes out today,
you're going to want to get it.
Joining us on Skype,
please welcome Kathie Lee Gifford y'all.
(cheering)
Oh my God I love her.
♪ I'll go and get mine ♪
♪ I'll wear my old lace ♪
♪ I'll wear my old leather ♪
- Hi guys.
- Oh my gosh.
You win for best entrance ever.
That was amazing.
What are you drinking right now?
Is that yours?
- That's my wine baby.
- Your wine is good.
You've given me your wine
before it is so good.
So wait, you just moved to Nashville.
So did you do that to write
songs, I know you write a lot?
- Is the show going on yet?
- Yes, this is actually the interview.
- Well then let me get comfortable.
Yeah, no, no.
I moved to Nashville because
I was working here with Brett James
on the music for this movie that I wrote
called 'Then Came You' with
the amazing Craig Ferguson.
And so Brett and I were
writing all the music together
for the movie
and I was here for almost
a year and I just thought
why am I so fricking
happy all the time here?
And I realized, it's the culture,
it's the creative culture
but it's also the faith culture here.
It's the kindness of people here
and the joy that they have.
Nobody's talking about the you know,
after you vote then let's
get together and have a drink
and write a song.
- I know, I love it.
Have you started a new
chapter of your life?
Dating life like in Nashville?
Cause that's a different breed of men
than where you were.
- You know well my husband
has been gone now five years.
I know where he is and
I'll see him someday.
But in the meantime,
you know I didn't date
until like a year ago.
It was about four years.
I just didn't want to.
- Yeah.
- And I was so busy with all
my projects and moving here.
But about a year ago my friends,
you know it's always your friends that go
you've got to get out there.
You know I go,
Why? I've got a full, rich, good life.
And so they said, well just have some fun.
So I went out with about maybe four guys
sweet guys.
I mean, great guys,
they just weren't my guy, you know.
It's gotta be the right guy.
I had the right guy for 31 years
and I'm not going to settle
for less than that next time.
- Don't do it.
I mean, that's amazing too.
I mean amazing for you,
but not for maybe all the
men that you might date.
So I think there's a high
bar that's already been set
and I say you keep it there.
- Yeah.
- So Dolly Parton wrote
the forward for your book.
So how long have y'all been friends?
- I've known Dolly probably
40 years, maybe more.
I first came to Nashville in 1978.
So do the math, which
I'm not very good at.
I was doing a sitcom called,
what is it called?
Oh, 'Hee Haw Honeys'
based on the Hee Haw Show.
And I met her, I met the Gatlins,
I met Barbara Mandrell,
I met Kenny Rogers
so many wonderful country people
and fell in love with Nashville,
it was a very different city there
and loved the culture, loved the music,
I loved the people.
Everybody just shows up and makes music,
you know that Kelly.
It's what you do.
- Yeah. They love it.
And it's just an everyday thing.
It's like everyday that ends in Y there.
And I think that's what's so creative
and it's called music city.
Everybody always says just country music.
It's not though.
There's rock, there's pop.
There's so many different
genres going on there.
So in your book, you talk
about what happened to you
at the Super Bowl.
Can you tell that story?
Cause I mean,
I have had to do that at
the Super Bowl as well,
and it is already nerve wracking.
Can you tell everybody what happened?
- Yeah, I was...what year was it?
It was 1990, I think it was six.
I think it was...no 1995.
Super Bowl 29 and I was asked
to sing the national anthem,
which is a you know a huge honor.
And yet at the same time it's terrifying.
I mean, that goes worldwide
and you don't even want to,
Barry Manilow had said to
me right before I did it,
he did it the year before.
And Barry's been a great
friend through all these years
and he said, Kathy,
no matter what you do, do
not look up at the scoreboard
and look at how many people
are going to be watching.
Don't do it, don't do it.
- Oh good lord don't tell her that.
- Now I'll tell you the story.
It was, you know
we have something called
final looks in our business
which is we're ready to go,
hair and makeup get over there
do whatever final touches
you're going to do.
Cause we're ready.
And
so my hairdresser by
mistake does hairspray on me
and goes in my right eye,
boom, right in my right eye.
And I'm going blinded from that.
And then my makeup artist is working on me
on the other side and she has a
- A wand.
- A mascara wand boom,
right into my left eye.
So I'm walking out like,
they had to leave me.
They don't wait for you at the Superbowl.
They're leading me out
and I can hear that everybody's screaming.
I can hear all this noise
and I'm going Oh, Jesus,
help me Jesus, help me.
I get there
and then of course the
orchestration starts.
You can hear the orchestra, full orchestra
and it's time for me to
sing of all the lyrics.
♪ Oh say can you, ♪
what...see.
(laughing)
- Oh my God that's awesome.
So anyway you sent me some
t-shirts with phrases on them.
Can you tell us about these?
Because this is hilarious.
So this one says,
"I'm sorry you must be
confusing for someone
"who cares what you think"
Which I'm totally in to.
- I love that one.
I want to make tons of those.
- This is actually my
favorite though okay.
"Don't confuse my
kindness with stupidity."
I'm looking at you.
- Yeah, because it's
like I choose to be kind,
but I'm not stupid.
- Yes. Let's say it again.
Don't confuse my kindness with stupidity.
Exactly. It's a good one.
Okay. So y'all Kathy Lee's new book,
'It's Never Too Late' is out right now.